ja nicht wie ich sagen imports
mittlerweile frustrierten ein bisschen
armin nach jetzt lust am untergang also
wir glaube ich haben uns alle durch das
trio gestern gequält ich vermute ist und
das fasziniert mir bist also inzwischen
schon mehr als beunruhigt wie sehr die
union eigentlich im ärgern sterben zu
sieht also man muss schon dazusagen dass
armin laschet gestern in der minderzahl
war also es war eigentlich 4 gegen eins
in dieser sendung und trotzdem hat das
kein einziges mal geschafft seinen punkt
zu machen und er kam obwohl ihm sogar
punkt appelle zugespielt wurden als
erster geschafft in anderen zuzustimmen
wo das rad beim thema innere sicherheit
irgendwo herum zu mehr anderen und mit
dem punkt nicht zu treffen das ist
einfach wirklich schon nur mehr schmerzt
also ich glaube er hat schon die inhalte
aber es ist einfach wirklich zu wenig zu
spät dass diese muss die union im
wahlkampf bringt niemand interessiert
das fünfzigste sofortprogramm jetzt zur
ost west also es ist wirklich
haarsträubend und das macht mich ratlos
aber immer denkt er dann bleibt eine
wählerschaft wirklich unbedingt weil es
kann es mir wirklich nicht vorstellen
dass jeder mensch in diesem land sehr
viel menschen oder scholz wählen wollen
ist es geht mir nicht in den kopf und
die liegen jetzt irgendwie brach und
deswegen ist das mein moment des tages
ich stimme dir voll zu ich glaube es war
ein absoluter katastrophen auftritt von
armin laschet vor allem auch deshalb
weil er immer nach hinten verwiesen hat
ja damals haben wir das gemacht und 1990
und klaus töpfer und dann gab es noch
jenes und solches anstatt zu sagen ich
stehe auch für die zukunft und ich will
irgendwas tun in der zukunft und dann
haben rot grün auf der anderen seite ihm
immer entgegen gehauen was sie vorhaben
nämlich gemeinsam mindestlohn wir wollen
den rentnern helfen und denjenigen
helfen also viel viel konkretere punkte
und ich frage mich mittlerweile wie
schlecht sind diese berater wie armin
laschet auf das ganze vorbereitet habe
es schaffte zumindest zumindest eines
dieser trient muss der mann noch für
sich entscheiden weil das adenauer haus
hat doch so viel kohle sie müssten sich
doch mal den einen oder anderen ich weiß
nicht warum haben sie nicht einmal
gefragt zum trainieren oder ich weiß es
nicht er kennt sich in polit-talkshows
aus ja also irgend jemand der das drauf
hat und er sagt armin so muss das machen
und erzieherin durchsagen verein hätte
ich natürlich nicht aber ich hätte es
auch nicht so gut rüberbringen können
wie andere die seit jahrzehnten
geschäft sind aber also da fasse ich mir
einen kopf wo sind diese ganzen ständen
millionen hin also hat nicht geholfen
dass da so viel an die cdu gespendet
wurde in den vergangenen monaten alles
liegt brach und ich glaube für eine oder
andere wirtschaftschef fühlt sich
richtig ärgern da so wahnsinnig aus
falsch jetzt
sind wir ehrlich angela merkel war auch
immer eine schlechte wahlkämpferin sogar
ein richtig miserabel aber die du
erzählst
helmut kohl war auch kein guter
wahlkämpfer die cdu ist bekannt dafür
dass sie richtig miserables wahlkämpfe
macht und trotzdem gewinnt und das ist
auch in dieser woche könnte es passieren
dass wir alle der meinung sind das war
der schlechteste wahlkampf aller zeiten
von der union und trotzdem am
sonntagabend 25,1 prozent erstehen und
armin laschet kanzler wird was sagen das
hab ich übrigens nun gestritten also ich
glaube dass die umfragen trat ihm auch
wirklich mit ganz und gar dass die union
wirklich besser vielleicht sogar sehr
viel besser rauskommen will das jetzt
dasteht trotzdem finde ich es eben
erstaunlich und deswegen meine
formulierung vom lust am untergang also
trotzdem davor und denkt sich das kann
ja nicht alles gewesen sein also im alle
power die dahintersteht alle die
mannschaft abgesehen davon dass man sie
fragt wo typen wie jens spahn eigentlich
sind also wie man
offensichtlich also das aber ich teile
diese meinung aber das liegt nicht am
guten wahlkampf irgendwie sondern glaube
vielleicht doch ein bisschen an dem was
sie vorher möchte und werde immer der
war mir immer den niedergang auf armin
laschet ich denken wir mal ich hab
gestern auch dass das trial geschaut und
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen fakten mäßig
wallaschek immer noch den beiden
überlegen er ist fertig der
charismatiker aber er hat wenigstens
freiheit eigenverantwortung bei den
anderen beiden habe ich nur gelernt der
staat soll für alles sorgen der staat
das wird dann hat hier nicht mehr nichts
mehr also eigentlich soll jeder vom
staat abhängig sein und jedem wird es
gut gehen in diesem jahr verstehen den
falschen fand die form der
gesprächsführung auch an schwierige
themensetzung es ging ja da habe ich nur
darum wieder stark nach dem bürger sonst
das geld auch eben also ganz schlimm es
ging wirklich nur darum was kann der
bürger zum staat verlagern und da konnte
irgendwie armin laschet im gegen die
zweiten mindestlohn minister konnte im
regal immer gewinnen also ich bin ja
ganz bei dir dass die inhalte die ihr
präsentiert hat nämlich zu sagen muss
die wirtschaft stärken man schafft
arbeitsplätze und dann die zehn leuten
wieder besser aber es war einfach
grün-rot ausgelegt diese befragung des
fand es ganz ehrlich ganz schlimmes
geführt war auch und dann eben hinten
raus ein bisschen innere sicherheit
darüber wissen
also dass eine werbung
aber auf ihre frage wie konnte das
passieren es gibt natürlich eine lange
geschichte es war ein doppelter
strategischer achsbruch die union hat
selber viel zu lange mit sich gestritten
werden chef wird und dann haben sie noch
mit der csu gestritten und dann war auch
die zeit eines strategisch geplanten
wahlkampf sind ja da also manchmal sind
die dinge auch sehr handwerklich und
naja wenn ich auf der anderen seite oder
scholz sehen und dann habe ich dieses
gästen und dann habe ich walter borjans
und kevin kühnert ida immer hinter mir
lauern also das finde ich jetzt nicht
eine einfachere situation als das bringt
wir haben sie gut gelaunt
aktionär bei keine partei ich bin nicht
normal berichtet dass ich keine
objektive sicht heimbringen für mich ist
ganz klar mein land ist er meist
unterschätzte kandidat dagegen wort der
wird durch umfragen denen nicht
überhaupt nicht trauen wie diese für
mich skurrile olaf scholz dieser
trojanische scholz der patron zeit
gesagt da weißt du nicht was drin steckt
das gesagte gehabt also habe ich sie
interpretiert
ausgesprochen
der ferrari laschet ist mit abstand der
vernünftigste kandidat und den ich mal
den check machen bei mich sozusagen
einen inneren bullshit detektor
hinterfrage ich sage ich einfach bei
laut muss ich sagen der hat ein paar
sätze gesagt wo ich sagen muss das ist
nicht unvernünftig aber es stimmt da
sehen wir uns ja einig er hat die chance
ist noch nicht gepackt zu wenig
kampfgeist aber
er ist
herzlich habt ihr habt in der deutschen
geschichte in den letzten 150 jahren
habe die so viel intensität power drama
horror-thriller geister kabinett gehabt
armin laschet das ist die rückkehr des
deutschen peter meyer aber
merkel gekommen ist hat man sich der
maßnahme die schuhe abgeputzt also dann
hat die kann das gar nicht wie haben sie
ausgemacht rot rot ziehen er ausgemacht
in der wahlnacht als sie ihn besiegt
hatte also unterschätzt mir diesen armin
laschet nicht wir schauen jetzt war
sondern höchstens aber das ist der punkt
ein ganz kurz weil ich genau diese
dieses wahlduell und so fahren die die
elefantenrunde danach glaube das wird
ganz spannend denn was ist denn
eigentlich wenn olaf scholz nur ein
prozent davon oder armin laschet ganz
nah dran was passiert dann wird dann die
cdu ihn trotzdem münchen weil man sagt
okay unser barometers zehn runter und
deswegen geht das nicht oder er setzt
sich dann armin laschet er hin und sagt
na ja jetzt mal abwarten ist wieder da
und dann muss christian lindner
entscheiden am sonntag um 18 uhr 1
beginnt koalitionskrieg ado wenn die
wirklich so nah beieinander sind also
innerhalb von einem oder anderthalb
prozent punkten dann ist es eine frage
der politischen geschicklichkeit wer
bringt welche parteien wie zusammen
psychischen ist es fällt vollkommen
offen und armin laschet hat eine
außergewöhnliche begabung der ist ja ein
last minute mensch er hat damals den
ministerpräsidenten wahl gewonnen obwohl
der eine woche vorher genau so weit
zurücklag wie jetzt er hat den märz
besiegt obwohl die umfragen den märz
hier sein und alle da dann war es bei
söder das gleiche wie konnte der serbe
sie ja auch in der letzten minute
eigentlich nur in einer nacht und
deswegen würde es mich nicht wundern
wenn der in dieser woche auf einmal
daran glaubt und abstrakt abend ist die
cdu vorne und die alte republik stand ja
nur dann ist aber die frage ob die
grünen das wir gestern jahren die
sozialdemokraten rein getuschelt haben
willens sind eine jamaika koalition
einzugehen weil die andere optionen die
er auch in dem raum schwebt über die
niemand so gerne spricht deutschland
koalition oder kenia es ganz schlimm zu
machen kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
sich das noch mal antun prozent messe
ganz anders schwierig sich noch eine
kleine anmerkung über sie wie ihr das
beurteilt habt aber diese geste vom olaf
scholz da am schluss diese überhebliche
feldherren herrenreiter gäste aus dem
inland etwas gesagt hat und all star in
seiner ganzen herrlichkeit geschmunzelt
hat also die hybris der macht enorm an
die macht erobert hat das kann sich also
gemäß den gesetzen der griechischen
tragödie auch dann noch reichlich
doppel waren belasteten und sonst so
schlecht muss man sagen als dass er da
irgendwelche punkte
und jetzt da momentan ein wir reden
jetzt über das trial und da muss man
doch sagen es geht da auch um den
eindruck um die authenzität um das
entertainment um das wie ich rüber komme
und da ist armin laschet einfach
untergegangen ja mein gott dann habe ich
zwei leute gegen mich irgendwann in
brüssel und habe vielleicht zehn leute
gegen kann ich doch nicht sagen das war
unfair und rot grün ist da jetzt
irgendwie zusammen ein dann muss ich
stärke zeigen und klar macht nach ihr
seid schon eine koalition moment mal ja
dann muss ich irgendwie dagegen hämmern
und das hat er gar nicht gepackt dass
mir jemand gesagt ein kandidat der das
auch ein comic der können nicht gewinnen
nach den gut sei es auch aus würselen
erzeugt und deshalb da war ich mit
diesem geografischen determinismus der
anzuwenden aber noch einmal ich meine
vielleicht ist lautet einfach
authentisch langweilig das muss man auch
akzeptieren aber es ist wenigstens
authentisch pop schon zu authentisch ist
obwohl
ich große fragezeichen setzt wie bitte
findest du arsch ein langweiliger als
olaf scholz also urlaub kreuz ist für
mich wirklich so der inbegriff verletzte
schwerpunktbereich die famila shell aber
was sie aber gut für deutschland dass
wir jetzt schon darüber sprechen bei
einer langweiligkeit skala aufhörens 12
also ich deswegen am meisten nur das
kanzleramt rechnet also da sind wir
angekommen
[Musik]